>> A NEW YORK CITY FAMILY VISITING
RELATIVES IN TURKEY ARE AMONG
THE VICTIMS OF THIS DEADLY
EARTHQUAKE.
BARACK FARIQ, HIS WIFE KIMBERLY
AND TWO SONS, 2-YEAR-OLD HANS A,
1-YEAR-OLD BILAL WERE FOUND.
THEY HAD BEEN STAYING NEAR THE
EPICENTER OF THE SECOND DEADLY
EARTHQUAKE.
SO JOINING US NOW TO TELL US
ABOUT HER SISTER,
BROTHER-IN-LAW, TWO NEPHEWS,
KIMBERLY'S YOUNGER SISTER, SAMBA
SALAZAR.
THANK YOU.
WE KNOW IT'S ROUGH.
WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW?
>> FIRST AND FOREMOST, I WANT
PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT THIS IS A
BIG PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IN TURKEY
AND IN SYRIA, AND ALTHOUGH I
LOST MY FAMILY, THERE ARE
CURRENTLY STILL PEOPLE UNDER
THERE.
THERE ARE CHILDREN.
THE NUMBER OF THE DEATH TOLL,
IT'S RISING, AND THE ONLY THING
I THINK THAT WE ASK IS HAVING
THE HELP, THE AWARENESS THAT
THIS IS STILL HAPPENING, AND
JUST GETTING AS MANY PEOPLE, ALL
HANDS, ALL HANDS ON DECK.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WHEN I FOUND
OUT THAT MY SISTER AND THE REST
OF MY FAMILY WAS MISSING, THERE
WAS NO RESCUE TEAM.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
BUILDING COLLAPSED AND IT WAS
JUST THREE PEOPLE ON SITE AND
MANPOWER BEING USED JUST FOR ONE
LOCATION BECAUSE AT THAT TIME
EVERYTHING WAS CHAOTIC.
EVERYONE WAS A PRIORITY.
SO IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT.
THIS IS REALLY DIFFICULT TO SEE
THIS.
SO WE'RE ALL VERY BROKEN IN MY
FAMILY.
AND ME AND MY SISTER, OUR HEARTS
ARE BROKEN.
>> CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THEM?
>> SO MY SISTER WAS SIX YEARS
OLDER THAN ME.
SHE WAS VERY GRACEFUL.
SHE WAS VERY -- SHE AS VERY
LOVABLE.
SHE WAS VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT SHE DID AND SHE
CERTAINLY PUT EVERYONE'S NEEDS
ABOVE HER OWN.
AND MY BROTHER-IN-LAW WAS VERY,
VERY, VERY HELPFUL IN THE
COMMUNITY.
HE WAS VERY SELFLESS.
HE WAS EXTREMELY INTELLIGENT.
AND ALL HE WANTED TO DO WAS
HELP.
HELP THE COMMUNITY.
HE WAS VERY -- HE WAS DONATING
TO AFRICA.
HE WAS DONATING -- HE WAS VERY
ACTIVE WITH NON-PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS.
WE'RE REALLY BROKEN.
>> DO YOU WANT TO TELL US ABOUT
YOUR NEPHEWS?
>> MY NEPHEWS.
SORRY.
>> IT'S OKAY.
WE SEE THEM.
THEY ARE BEAUTIFUL.
>> MY FIRST NEPHEW, HIS NAME IS
HAMSA, HE IS 2 YEARS OLD.
AND MY LITTLE ONE WAS A YEAR
OLD.
AND THERE ARE NO WORDS I CAN
DESCRIBE HOW MY FAMILY IS
FEELING, HOW THEY WERE TAKEN
AWAY SO SOON.
THEY WERE JUST CHILDREN.
AND WE'RE MOURNING.
WE'RE MOURNING, YOU KNOW.
WE WERE JUST -- WE HAD SO MUCH
HOPE.
OUR HOPE WAS TO SEE HIM IN
PROGRAMS AND ENROLL HIM IN
SCHOOL, AND NOW WE DON'T HAVE
THAT.
WE'VE LOST ALL OUR HOPE.
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING.
MY MOM AND DAD, THEY ARE VERY
BROKEN.
IT'S LIKE STARTING OVER FROM
NOTHING.
IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT.
>> HOW CAN WE HELP YOU?
EVERYONE IS GOING TO HEAR YOUR
STORY AND BE SO TOUCHED BY IT.
>> THIS IS A HUGE -- AGAIN, THIS
IS VERY CHAOTIC.
THIS IS A HUGE LOSS THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING IN MY FAMILY.
AND NOT ONLY IF MY FAMILY, THE
WHOLE COUNTRY IN TURKEY.
MY SISTER AND THE KIDS, THEY
WERE U.S. AMERICAN CITIZENS.
THEY WERE BORN HERE.
THEY WERE RAISED HERE.
AND MY PARENTS AND ME, WE HAVE,
YOU KNOW, ACCEPT AND MADE A HUGE
GREAT SACRIFICE IN UNDERSTANDING
AND COMING TO TERMS THAT ONCE WE
FOUND OUT WE WERE READY TO GO ON
THE NEXT FLIGHT TO TURKEY, BUT
WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT OPTION
BECAUSE THE ROADS WERE CRACKED.
THERE WAS A RISK.
OUR LIVES WERE AT RISK IF WE
WENT.
THEY WEREN'T LETTING PEOPLE
INSIDE THE CITY WHERE THE
EPICENTER WAS OCCURRING.
THEY WERE IN KAHRAMANMARAS, A
TOWN, A SMALL TOWN WHERE ONCE
THE BUILDINGS COLLAPSED, 80 TO
95% OF THE TOWN WAS COMPLETELY
DEMOLISHED.
IT WAS VERY DIFFERENT TO JUST
GET A MACHINE IN TO HELP COLLECT
AND PICK UP THE CEMENT, BIG
BLOCKS OF CEMENT, ROCKS.
YOU KNOW, SO JUST WE LOST FIVE
FAMILY MEMBERS.
MY TWO NEPHEWS, MY
BROTHER-IN-LAW, MY SISTER.
AND MY BROTHER-IN-LAW'S MOTHER
AND HIS DAD.
SO MY BROTHER-IN-LAW'S FATHER
WAS THE ONLY SURVIVOR.
>> AND HE JUST HAD OPEN-HEART
SURGERY, YOU SAID?
>> HE HAD OPEN-HEART SURGERY.
AND HE BASICALLY SAW HIS
BUILDING COLLAPSE BEFORE HIS OWN
EYES AND HE COULDN'T DO ANYTHING
AND HE CALLED MY MOM AND HE
SAID, MOM, HE SAID, BARAK,
MADELEINE, HAMSA, THEY ARE GONE.
THEY LEFT.
AND SO HE SPENT OVER 12 HOURS
DIGGING AND JUST FINDING PEOPLE
TO HELP HIM DIG BECAUSE THE
MACHINES WEREN'T ABLE TO GO IN.
>> WELL, LISTEN, WE ARE -- THERE
AREN'T WORDS.
AND WE KNOW THAT THIS IS TOUGH
FOR YOU, AND THERE ARE MANY
FAMILIES HERE IN AMERICA WHO
HAVE LOVED ONES THERE AND HAVE
LOST.
AND SO WE ARE ALL THINKING ABOUT
YOU AND OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS
ARE WITH YOU.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU COMING
IN.
WE KNOW THIS ISN'T EASY TO DO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR STRENGTH AND
YOUR COURAGE AND DIGNITY AND WE
ARE SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.